GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
COMMENSURATE OF COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER IN RESPONSE THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TODAY
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCE TEAM AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY IT
DOESN'T ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL I WILL ASK ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT BE
PRESIDENT REPORTING TO A POLICE
WITNESS DOUBLE SHARP FORM AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TWO WEEKS AT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND WORKERS
TO COMPETE BACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL BETWEEN. THE QUORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND- ANY INDIVIDUAL
WAS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS NEEDED
. TODAY WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA S. R. S. J. R.
EIGHT WAS PULLED AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. BUT BEFORE WE
START OUR BILL PRESENTATION. I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF PRINCE AND HUMAN
SERVICES BACK. AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU OVER
THE LEGISLATIVE HERE. I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO- WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATE MERCER SHE WHO'S-
UP IN HER NEW ROLE AS STAFF
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES WERE EXCITED TO.
HAVE YOU IN YOUR NEW ROLE AND-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS THE YEAR GOES MOVES ALONG
. I BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS
ARE ON THE BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM- CONSULTING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FURTADO
YOUR. I GOT OUT HERE JONES.
JONES HERE COURTESY YOU'RE
PROTESTING HERE FROM OTHER. CAN
PRESENT HERE AND HERE. HI THERE
AS WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
AND WE WELCOME A SENATOR
SKINNER- SHE'S HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL. SIX FOUR ONE. YES
THANKS SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE
STUDENT HUNGER RATE IS 10%
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
. WHICH I THINK ALL OF US- WOULD
LIKE TO SEE DIFFERENT- SP SIX
FORTY ONE WHICH I'M PRESENTING
TODAY BUILDS ON LEGISLATION THAT
I AUTHORED WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND
THAT LEGISLATION ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY WORKING
GROUP ON COLLEGE HUNGER. HOW
MANY OF THE WORKING GROUP'S
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
INTO REGULATIONS BUT ONLY ONE
HAS BEEN CODIFIED. BECAUSE
COLLEGE HUNGER IS STILL SO HIGH
THERE'S MORE FOR US TO DO SO SB
SIX FORTY ONE CODIFIES MANY
POSITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS. OF
THE WORK GROUPS THAT HAVE NOT
YET BEEN CODIFIED. HOW FRESH IS
OUR BEST TOOL TO COMBAT COLLEGE
HUNGER. 46% OF THE STUDENTS THAT
APPLY FOR CALFRESH ASSISTANCE
ARE FOOD INSECURE HOMELESS FOR
BOOKS. AND DATA INDICATES THAT
MANY OF THE STUDENTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION OR STUDENTS OF COLOR
FEMALE. SO- BY HELPING THE
STUDENTS WITH THEIR FOOD
INSECURITY WE CAN SUPPORT THEM
TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE
THEY WILL TAKE LESS TIME TO
GRADUATE POTENTIALLY TAKE ON
LESS COLLEGE DEBT ONTO WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- PURCELL
PROVIDING. THEIR TESTIMONY AND
WE HAVE RUBEN KANETO FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
WIDE BASIC NEEDS COMMITTEE AND
ROCIO PEREZ WHO IS A GRAD
STUDENT AT UCLA. THANK YOU AND
AT THIS MOMENT WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THOSE THAT ARE HERE DOES
FRANCE APART BUT I ALSO WANT TO
INCLUDE THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARING
AIDS TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE
STRESSED ME IT'S A TWO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED IN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR ALL OF THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. DO WE HAVE THE
PRIMARY- WITNESS RUBEN KANETO.
YEAH I'M HERE SO I'M I'M SORRY I
GOT LOCKED IN AND- INSTRUCTIONS
SO DO I DO I OFFER MY PREPARED
REMARKS OR ONLY K. IF I'M IN
SUPPORT OR NOT. NO NO PLEASE
PLEASE BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INVITATION TO SUPPORT SB SIX
FORTY ONE. MY NAME IS EBONY
KANETO I'D- ADD YOU CAN PARK THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FUTURE EQUITY
INITIATIVES I ALSO CALLED SHARE
OUR SYSTEM MY BASIC NEEDS
COMMITTEE. AND I'M A MEMBER OF
OUR CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
BASIC NEEDS THE LION OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS CABINET. WHICH INCLUDE
THE ARTS DISTRICT THAT MEANT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND YET YOU.
WE THANK YOU SENATOR SCANNER FOR
YOUR INTRODUCTION OF SB SIX
FORTY ONE AND URGING A VOTE ON
THAT MEASURE. CALIFORNIA HAS LED
A MOVEMENT TO WORK IMPROVING OUR
UNDERSTANDING. AND CARE FOR
STUDENT BASIC NEEDS. AND
OFFENDER AB NINETEEN THIRTY AND
THE WORK REPATRIATED CONVENES
IDEA FACT HAVE PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THAT
LEADERSHIP. I'M PROUD TO HAVE
SERVED AS A COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
THAT CREATION ALONG WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM COUNTY. AND
EACH COLLEGE BACK MEANT STUDENT
GROUPS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE ISSUE HAD
GAINED SIGNIFICANT AND GROWING
NATIONAL ATTENTION AND MANY ARE
LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA FOR THE
EXAMPLE THE FORWARD MOVEMENT. WE
LOOK CHEAP AS WELL AS IDEAS FOR
FURTHER POLICY CHANGES NEEDED.
AT THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS.
UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL OUR
FRACTURED FINANCIAL A PROFOUND
AND OUR STATE COST OF LIVING OUR
FIX. OUR LARGEST DEFENSE TO
PREVENT STUDENTS FROM
EXPERIENCING POVERTY HUNGER HOW
THE THING THAT HEALTH AND
ACADEMIC CRISES. IF THE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING A
SOCIAL SERVICES THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE. AND TO
EXPAND THOSE SERVICES. OKAY TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMUNITY HAVE
PUBLISHED BOTH ACADEMIC STUDIES
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REPORT. ONE
FORM B. AFTER. OUR STATE HAS
PASSED LEGISLATION AND BUDGET
ITEM. THE ACT THAT. HAS ROLLED
OUT NEW OFF COUNTY LETTERS AND
MATERIALS AND CAMPERS THAT HAVE
EITHER LAUNCHED OR SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDED OUR CAMPUS BASIC NEEDS
EVERYTHING. AND JUST TO OVER
YEARS AGO IN FEBRUARY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THAT DOES TO A VIRTUAL
WORLD. OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS HIGHER ED PROFESSIONALS
GOVERNMENT STAFF AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS CONVENE. FOR THE FIRST
EVER CABINET SUMMIT THESE
RELATE. PARTNERSHIP AMONG MEN
CAN TO. AND FOR ALL OF THE
EFFORT. THAT IS WHY AT THE FIX
FORTY ONE PM. THE MANY THE
THINGS THAT HE- FROM ALL OF THE
CAN BE IN FAITH. FOUR LEFT
OBJECT MATTER AT AND- THEMSELVES
AT THE NEXT MAJOR BILL TWENTY
BANK THIS MOVEMENT TOWARD.
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE THEY'RE-
CREATING DATA INFRASTRUCTUE FOR
QUALITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
FINALLY CHANGING THE CULTURE
TOWARDS CARING AND STARVING
COLLEGE STUDENT AT THAT SCALE
NEEDED. AT THREE THIRTY FORTY
ONE WILL IMPROVE OVER A MILLION
STUDENTS LIVES PER YEAR. ALL
FIFTY THREE COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES AND MOVE US TOWARD
MAXIMIZING FEDERAL DOLLARS
COMING TO OUR STATE GOING
THROUGH STUDENT. STATE EMPLOYEE
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND THE WELL
BEING OF OUR STATE FUTURE ON
BEHALF OF PREVIOUS PRESENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS WHO WILL
BENEFIT FROM OUR CONTINUED
FORWARD MOTION. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX FORTY ONE AND. WE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU AND- AT
THIS MOMENT WE MOVE ON TO
WITNESS NUMBER TWO AND JUST
WANNA REMIND- AS EVERYONE THAT
WE HAVE THE THREE MINUTE-
PRESENTATION A LOT FOR EACH
WITNESS ROC OPPRESSIVE YOU'RE ON
THE CALL PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
VACATION TO SUPPORT SB SIX FOR
ONE MY NAME HER FEEL BETTER WHEN
I'M A FIRST YEAR MPP STUDENT AT
UCLA. DURING ORIENTATION THE
UCLA HEALTH CHRISTIAN MISSION
AND HOPE THAT OUR PRESENTATION
WITH A STEP BY STEP GUIDE ON HOW
TO APPLY FOR CALFRESH AND
OFFERED REAL TIME ASSISTANCE
DURING THEIR DOING OFFICE HOURS
TO COMPLETE AN APPLICATION. I
DECIDED TO SIGN UP FOR THEIR
OFFICE HOURS TO APPLY FOR
CALFRESH BECAUSE MY SALARY AT
THE GRADUATE RESEARCH STUDENTS
WHAT'S NOT THE VISION TO COVER
MY PERSONAL EXPENSES INCLUDING
RENT AND TUITION WHILE ALSO
FINANCIALLY ASSISTING MY FAMILY
AND STILL HAVING LESS MONEY LEFT
OVER. FOR FOOD WHAT THE ONGOING
EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC ONLINE
COMPOUND LIFTS LIKE MINE A
BUDGET FOR FOOD IS DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN AND HEALTHY FOOD
OPTIONS ARE OUT OF THE QUESTION.
BUT HOW FRESH I NOW HAVE A
BUDGET FOR FOOD THAT DOES NOT
CUT INTO MY BUDGET FOR RENT.
UTILITIES OR FOR FAMILY
EXPENSES. DO YOU FEEL LIKE HOW.
THIS WORKING. HELPFUL IN
ANSWERING MY QUESTION AND
FOLLOWING UP AFTER SUBMITTING MY
APPLICATION. INCLUDING THEIR ONE
WE FOLLOW UP TO ENSURE I HAD AN
INTERVIEW SCHEDULED AND THE ONE
MONTH FOLLOW UP TO ASK WHETHER
IT WAS APPROVED OR DENIED. OR
WHETHER I HAD RECEIVED AN EBT
CARD IN THE MAIL. THIS FOLLOWED
BY THE INITIATIVE TO HAVING A
POINT PERSON TO ASK QUESTIONS
WHAT'S CRUCIAL BECAUSE THE
FILTER INFORMATION SPECIFIC TO
UCLA. FRESHMAN MY GRADUATE
PROGRAM WAS APPROVED LOCAL
STUDENT PROGRAM WHERE STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN THESE PROGRAMS ARE
EXEMPT FROM THE STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY RULES FOR
PROFESSIONAL INSTABILITY. AND
OVERALL GET MY APPLICATION
APPROVED. HOW FRESH UP HELP ME
AFFORD FOOD WITHOUT HAVING TO
FURTHER STRETCH MY FAVORITES FOR
SCHOOL PERSONAL OR FAMILY
EXPENSES. NEED HELP FRESH
PROGRAM AT UCLA AND THEY THINK
ME ANSWERS HELP ME UNDERSTAND
THE COMPLEX. EXEMPTIONS AND
ROLLED IN CALFRESH. AND THEY'RE
CRUCIAL FOREIGN ROLLING ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS FOR. THE PROGRAM TO
RECEIVE THE EXTRA SUPPORT DURING
AND BEYOND THE PANDEMIC. THIS
BILL WILL REINFORCE RULES
ALREADY IN PLACE TO MAKE PROFITS
EASIER TO ACCESS FROM IT FOR
INCOME ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. LIKE
MYSELF THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I THANK YOU FOR PRESS- LET'S
MOVE ON TO ANYWAY. FOR SUPPORT.
AND ROOM FOR TWO ZERO THREE.
SCENE AND NONE ARE WE AT THIS
POINT WILL- TAKE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WANTED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FOUR ONE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAT BENDS ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR KEEP PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT ELEVEN AM YOU. IF YOU
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES AND CALL THE SUPPORT WHEN
IS THIS INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU I'M SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- IS THIS SUPPORT
FOR THE SCANNER BILL SIX FOUR
ONE YES THIS IS JUST AS A
REMINDER THIS IS A SO CALLED R.
S. B. SIX FOUR ONE- AND NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. ALL WHAT I'M MOST
DEFINITELY IN THE WRONG PLACE
BECAUSE I DON'T SUPPORT THE
SPELL AND- THANK YOU IN ORDER
FOR YOU ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
COMMENT. LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING PAULA
VAZQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
PART OF THE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I AM SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I'M PERPLEXED BY YOUR SYSTEM
I'M ASKING TO BE RE QUEUED IN
OPPOSITION BUT I KEEP POPPING UP
. THANK YOU YOU'LL HAVE TO QUEUE
UP FOR OPPOSITION THE ONES THAT
THAT TIME LINE TIME PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALEX YOU GO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU LINE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MY NAME IS MIKE DAVIS CAME WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD
BANK IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DEREK POCO WITHOUT
WALKING JUST REGIONAL FOOD BANK
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BECKY SILVA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
RAN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
RACHEL MONACO FROM SECOND
HARVEST THE SILICON VALLEY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE ABOUT FIVE MORE IN Q.
WILL GOING TO WHITE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS JEFF
MARSTON REPRESENTING FEEDING SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX FORTY
ONE AN HOUR THANKS TO SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING JUSTIN SONIC FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN
THE PORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NATALIE
CABLE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FOOD
BANK AND STRONG. ON THE PHONE I.
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MARGE SCHOTT CABIN WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO MORAN WILL
BANK IT SHALL SUPPORT SB SIX
FORTY ONE ASPECT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE LAST ONE IN Q. LIVES
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY.
THIRTEEN I HAVE NO FURTHER
WIDENING QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WHO WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS THINK YOU'RE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BUT IF THERE IS ANY OPPOSITION
PRESENT TODAY WE INVITE THEM TO
TESTIFY NOW- BUT LET'S MOVE TO
ANYONE ELSE'S HERE ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. THREE NINE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS A MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WANT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FOUR ONE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SIX FOUR ONE THAT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAT BENDS ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I JUST HAVE THE
ONE MINING Q. LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTEEN IS THAT
ME HAVE I FOUND MY WAY TO THE
CORRECT PLACE TO OPPOSE SENATE
BILL SIX FOUR ONE YES YES YOUR-
YOUR HONOR PLEASE BUT YOU DID
BUT YOU DIDN'T HAVE YOU DIDN'T
HAVE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
AND- YOU HAD TO WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS I'M
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND THIS
PROCESS A LITTLE BIT MORE DEAR I
SAY THE LACK OF PROCESS BECAUSE
THIS DOESN'T SEEM VERY
REPRESENTATIVE IMMEDIATELY A
LITTLE BIT ONE SIDED YOU PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON YOUR BILL AND- WOULD
LIKE TO. PUT THIS ON THE RECORD
IF YOU'D LIKE TO DO THAT. NOW
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LIKE TO
KNOW WHY I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHY
YOU DON'T HAVE A WITNESS AN
OPPOSITION I'D LIKE TO ACT AS
YOUR WITNESS AN OPPOSITION THERE
ISN'T A REASON I SHOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO. HEAR ALL ABOUT HEARING
THE VOICE OF THE PEOPLE AREN'T
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT MY
RESPONSIBILITY I MEAN THAT IS
OR- AND IF I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
PLEASE. MAKE IT MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS OR OTHERWISE WE WILL
PROCEED WITHOUT. YOUR COMMENTS.
OKAY SO MY COMMENTS SO I GET
THREE MINUTES OR WAS IT SIX NOW
BECAUSE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION OF THE STATE OR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THIS
BILL. SO IT CAME AS A WAY TO END
OKAY. WE WANT TO HEAR WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON THANK YOU IT
FELL OFF. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. WELL
THANK YOU MODERATOR- THANK YOU
TO ALL THOSE THAT CALLED IN AND
SUPPORT AND ALL THOSE ARE CALLED
IN. OPPOSITION AS WELL AT THIS
MOMENT I'M GOING TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FOR THE
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE OUT
SENATOR CORTEZ THE- IT JUST
COMMENTS- THE- IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- JUST WANTED TO SAY THE
OFFICE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA I THINK- MOST OF US- WITH
EXPERIENCE IN OUR OWN DISTRICTS
ARE HEARING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AND SEEMS TO TEST X.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN- AROUND THIS
CONCERNED- FOOD INSECURITY AND
IT SORT OF HAND IN HAND WITH
WITH HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW
AMONG- ESPECIALLY- IN THE POST
SECONDARY. SPACE SO THAT SAID
THAT YOU JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND- IT IF
YOUR- A CONSIDERING TAKING ALL
CO AUTHORS AT ANY POINT- I WOULD
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO COME ON AS
A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL. GREAT
I'D BE HAPPY TO. ADDRESS THE
COURT. THANK YOU SENATOR AND-
AND WITH THAT- WALL DIFFERENT-
SOMEBODY ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK I'D
BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL- AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER AND
CENTER PATH. NOW I ALSO WANT TO
THANK- CENTER SCANNER FOR-
BRINGS BILL FORD ACTUALLY AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE GOT
MOVING THE BILL- AND- LOOKING
FORWARD TO VOTING FOR THE BILL
I'D ALSO POINT OUT THAT- WE DO
GIVE PEOPLE THE PUBLIC THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION. AND AND TURNS
TESTIMONY SO AGAIN- BRIEFLY
DISCUSSION. IN ADDITIONAL COM OR
QUESTIONS OKAY. WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR SCANNER AND- WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB SIX FOUR ONE. UP
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING REMARKS. THANKS SO MUCH
CHEERED THERE WAS ONE- I
MENTIONED THAT THE BILL CODIFIES
MANY THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
WORKING GROUP AND I WILL SAY
THAT FOR THOSE OF US WHO CARRY
BILLS THAT CREATE. A WORKING
GROUP SITS ON IT FEELS GOOD TO
SEE SOMETHING. ACTUALLY RESULT
FROM IT AND SO THAT WAS A VERY
PRODUCTIVE WORKING GROUP AND
THEY CAME UP WITH MANY GOOD
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THE BILL DOES. IS
THAT ONCE THE- CALFRESH WAS MORE
AVAILABLE ELIGIBILITY WAS MORE
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WHAT OUR
COUNTY WELFARE. DEPARTMENTS
EXPERIENCED WAS A RUSH OF
APPLICATIONS AT THE BEGINNING OF
EACH. SCHOOL SESSION. AND IT WAS
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO PROCESS.
AND SO ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS- ONE OF THE
THINGS IN THE BILL IS THAT IT
REQUIRES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WORK GROUP TO
DESIGN A CALFRESH APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT WOULD ACCOMMODATE.
THE LARGE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED AT THE START OF EACH
YEAR. IN ORDER TO HELP ARE. ON
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS
HANDLE THIS AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICOTTA I RETIRED OUT I JOHN
JONES I COURTESY I WORKED AT THE
I. HOW MODERN. TEN HI AND I. THE
FINAL VOTE IS FOR ZERO WELL AS
FOUR ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU OKAY AT THAT ISN'T THE
ONLY BILL THAT WE HAVE TODAY FOR
THIS HEARING BUT I DO WANT TO
BEFORE I CLOSE OUT PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- AND OR R. OR VICE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY ANY
CLOSING REMARKS GIVEN THIS IS
THE FIRST HEARING OF FIGURE FOR
THIS COMMITTEE. GOOD EVERYONE
ALL RIGHT WELL HAPPY NEW YEAR
EVERYBODY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WANT TO GET TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AT IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY- PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES KNOWLEDGE AND.